We've created several resources and
have assembled a team of
iOS developers to assist you in
building your portfolio of apps.
Links to each of these resources can
be found in the notes below this video.
>> First is the Udacity form.
This will be your primary resource for
seeking help on topics related to
our courses and your portfolio apps.
You'd actually coaches-
>> Like us.
>> And mentors regularly visit the form
to answer student questions and
provide guidance.
You may also find yourself helping other
students on the form from time to time.
A link to the form is provided below.
We recommend bookmarking this link.
>> Next, our one on one appointments
with the Udacity mentors.
Sometimes it's easier or
more helpful to speak with someone.
When that's the case, feel free to
schedule an appointment for a voice or
video chat with one of our mentors.
They're eager to help.
>> If you prefer text chat,
we have a select channel for
all of our current and former students.
This is another great way to
connect with your peers and
get the answer to a tough question.
>> When you're ready
to start looking for
iOS development jobs, we've assembled
a wealth of resources to assist you at
the Udacity Career Resource Center.
You will also be completing several
career projects as you progress through
the Nano degree, that will help
you polish your resume and
LinkedIn profile as well as prepare for
interviews.
>> Finally, be sure to check out
the Udacity student handbook for
general information
about our Nano Degrees.
As well as our student
community rules and policies.
>> Feel free to email
support@udacity.com
if you have any questions or
comments about this program.
>> We're excited to get started
let's make our first app.